hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play fear
amnesia okay you guys said that I need
to explore the rest of the house to try
to find the bucket of water to quench
the thirst of that there um thing and
therefore I need to um I don't know but
I need to explore the rest of the house
because obviously the string was not
where I was and hi hi
I even there buddy did you just bash
yourself in there
honk let me I'll hello I don't feel so
good I'm feeling very strange lately so
I locked myself in this room I don't
want to hurt more people you're ever
alone
how did you write the note out here if
you locked yourself in there or did you
do that preemptively to get to room here
to there booze man let me in love down a
dump a lot down loud down and dumb hello
baby oh no I don't know which one to
pick I guess I'll just have both of you
yeah what did I just see I couldn't tell
ha ha ha it went by almost too quickly I
saw like the same red dotted eyes hello
oh I get to go outside maybe I'll find a
bucket of water out there what was that
sound what what was that sound hello
what's all this then
ooh this looks nice hello baby I'll be
right there I'll be right with you just
gotta figure out something over here Oh
a water pump I guess I just need to find
a bucket now
Oh like oh well hello what's up wait a
minute
that that door was moving hang on
give me a rock to throw at it that door
was moving it was seriously moving ok
maybe not well pump I got it all right
let me go jump over here maybe hello
baby oh no I'm trying to get to you but
they're trying to keep our love apart no
way whatever so I need to find a bucket
that's what I need and I heard a sound
which probably meant the Moose man came
out of hiding
hello oh it's quiet now the door
it broke I hope that person is not after
me now Oh No
hello oh oh oh ok then
alright so someone got dismembered here
in the brutal fashion I hope it was that
guy
damn I have no idea where I put Miki ah
oh this isn't bad grammar they're all
pirates damn I have no idea where I put
Miki last time it was in one of my
shirts at least what I can remember her
are ok so that explains so much
Oh urn these angels be there winches are
ok so it's fear amnesia
do you be afraid of what lies in the
murky depths this is the worst pirate
impression ever oh come on I thought for
sure maybe I need to find a chisel boom
a basa head off of this funk ok now our
I need to find another way ah or maybe I
just need to bash the grate off of the
little thing where I drop my key and
then I'll make my way down into the
murky depths he'll get both me water
and Balki that's getting annoying I'm
done with that let's go back track a bit
because I obviously left a lot of the
house to question what was that
oh hello oh no there's not
boom Oh No ha ha ha hello these weird
flashbacks are not doing it for me oh
lordy I am moving slowly forward what am
I gonna find on the other side of this
door ah
get back here get back here you [ __ ]
come back oh lordy it's getting mighty
trippy not sure if I can handle this
this is pretty cool though I mean it's
got to be a really clever use of amnesia
game mechanic hello hi oh oh I got
pushed back ok so obviously that means
this way them ha ha ha ha oh my oh my
how are they doing this this is
incredible a more amazed than afraid
hello
hello ah ah what the piss was that what
was that supposed to be oh it's a
reminisce of the exploded guy it was
like some spider on the ground oh it's
so wrong stop it stop with the rear
doors lost me huh woo
no screw you [ __ ] I'm not following you
I'm going up here
I'm already been up here nothing up here
oh wait have I been up here
I remember whoa
this game is really messing with you
it's awesome and bad crowbar good
I got a crowbar now smash a smashy I
guess I'll follow the little girl now
cuz that's a good idea
hello hi hello maybe I was supposed to
follow her earlier and I just triggered
something happening now I have no idea
I don't really know okay so I got a
crowbar here which I could use on the
gate outside maybe now I don't really
know I'm not sure I've got a bunch of
stuff but I don't know what to do with
it I just need to find a bucket of water
I'm assuming there's gonna be a bucket
out here somewhere maybe we could use
this as a bucket the poisonous go and I
don't really know I don't know oh come
on I want to get out here I want to go
home there's got to be a way to get
through here alright whatever
maybe I can use this crowbar in one of
those doors upstairs but first let me
double-check downstairs to make sure
there's nothing to be used because I got
a hammer and a crowbar now and there's
got to be something that I can use them
on maybe I'm not sure what's up there
what's up there I bet I could stack some
boxes but I don't have enough boxes to
stack all right
oh the music has changed a lot
looky I like this I like this it all ha
ha ha ha ha ok there was nothing up here
right there's no doors there's no things
there's no levers there's nothing that I
need to use this on ergo this tool must
be used later NISS late ernest yeah
later this I must have skipped buy
something something really early I must
have like I must have found the machine
room key early on earlier than I was
supposed to or didn't get the crowbar
before I was supposed to I don't really
know so let's go try to use these this
crowbar and one of the UM the doors up
yonder maybe I'll get a bucket I don't
know no I just want to go home go stop
at stop with the whatever that sound is
I don't even know
ok let's try it no come on stop pass ah
come on what am I supposed to do let's
go back down this way I don't think
there was anything that I've skipped by
here but there's got to be a bucket
somewhere where's this that's the front
door but it's locked
right it's changed first I have to
explore the house ok ok that's blocked
up that was with the spider this is
where I started you go it's gotta be
something forward a bit um let me out
okay I'm officially explore oh ah oh
come on oh come on I see it
no I wait oh I see nothing in there oh I
thought I saw a bucket that's just the
edge of the intersection of those things
right there ok nevermind hello Spidey ah
man Oh
man are these pirates be getting to me
they be messing with men's minds there
be no treasure in here X don't mark the
spot in these parts
world's worst pirate award oh okay that
didn't actually do anything
aha arrr I see something over yonder way
I'll just make my way up and to the the
murky depths of the Attic are are you
don't want to be messing with me oh come
on I can't go here no no that's the only
way it's the only way I see maybe I can
just roll this up against those windows
there are are no Oh gah use the crowbar
on the boards oh I'm so stupid well
that's easy pork whoa come on use it
let's try this again yeah how about you
do something other than nothing wait try
it again ah I see ah come on
I'm moving my mouse do something what
you're shut up you kidding me right
you're kidding me right what the hell
are you kidding me what away
Wow i UK me move you [ __ ] move what oh
what oh there we go okay that's what I
thought okay I panicked a bit all right
the hammer is useless now so all that
was for me [ __ ] up on the stupid
planks why do I keep screwing up so much
ah what I am either the biggest idiot in
the world to jam a crowbar in so badly
I understand how stupid I am
maybe because I'm an idiot yeah I fry it
makes sense okay so I can tone it down
there now but now I have a saw why why
do I need to get these arbitrary tools
for arbitrary purposes doctor I'm a
cutter sharks I don't know I don't know
why why okay I have a saw now and I
don't know why I need it I will saw this
door Oh specially made for steel wait oh
god specially made for stealing my way
into a door made for stealing my entry
into a place I know where to use this
and I shall use it to maximum efficacy
haha some of the things in this game
make me go come on really really you
couldn't be more arbitrary it's too
textbook definition of pedantic Oh
shallow and pedantic shallow and
pedantic my ass
cut oh come on
what could you be used for it is so
arbitrary
it's still arbitrary let me look at my
notes oh oh maybe the door where the
lock was broken I could um I think I
could go maybe cut through that one I
don't know I don't know it's so
arbitrary oh okay whatever okay all
right obviously not downstairs cuz I've
already been there I think I already
tried it on the doors Oh golly gee
willikers mister stop it
no no I know I've been in here know
nothing let me double check there with
nothing oh man this is brutal
this is brutal I've already tried this I
tried this already it does not work it
does not work it doesn't work man smash
ha ha ha oh man ok I
I'm trying my best here gang I'm trying
but this game this particular custom
story is just messing with my mind so
I'm actually all at a dime so write in
the comments explain it to me as if I'm
five and I'm gonna look at whatever your
instance I'm going to go off so stupid
so um do that the crowbar thing I was
dumb about but getting a crowbar stuck
for a hammer I'm glad I found the hammer
and blah blah blah blah anyway let me
know what I need to do so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more video City I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Oh
ha
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
my god